>>> THE FISHER PRICE PLAY SETS,
SOME KIDS CAN BE FOUR-STAR
CHEFS.
SOME KIDS CAN WIN THE RACE.
BUT SOME JUST LONG TO BE
UNDERSTOOD.
INTRODUCING WELLS FOR SENSITIVE
LITTLE BOYS FROM FISHER PRICE.
WELLS FOR SENSITIVE BOYS TO WISH
UPON, CONFIDE IN, REFLECT BY.
SOME BOYS LIVE UNEXAMINED LIVES.
BUT THIS ONE'S HEART IS FULL OF
QUESTIONS.
JUST HEAR HOW MUCH HE LOVES THE
WELL.
>> YOU DON'T WANT TO DO THE
COMMERCIAL ANY MORE?
OKAY.
DO YOU WANT TO WATCH "Y TU MAMA
HAMBIEN"?
>> YEAH.
>> OKAY.
HE WANTS TO GO BACK TO THE WELL.
>> HE'LL ENJOY RUNNING HIS
LITTLE FINGERS AROUND THE WELL.
DAYS HE'S HAD TOO MUCH HE'LL
LEAN ON IT AND CONTEMPLATE HIS
REFLECTION.
SOME KIDS LIKE TO PLAY.
OTHERS SORT OF WAIT FOR
ADULTHOOD.
>> WHAT IS HE PUTTING IN THERE?
>> A SECRET.
>> HE'LL GROW UP TO HAVE A
WILDLY PASSIONATE AND SUCCESSFUL
CREATIVE LIFE.
BUT NOT JUST YET.
>> SPENCER!
SPENCER!
>> SPENCER?
>> YES, MOM?
>> ALSO, CHECK OUT OTHER COOL
NEW TOYS FOR OUR SENSITIVE BOY
LINE.
LIKE BALCONIES FOR WHEN THEY'RE
READY TO ANNOUNCE SOMETHING.
OR A SHATTERED MIRROR TO EXAMINE
THE COMPLEX CONTRADICTIONS OF
THEIR BEING.
>> IT'S WEIRD, I DON'T GET IT.
>> THAT'S BECAUSE IT'S NOT FOR
YOU.
BECAUSE YOU HAVE EVERYTHING.
EVERYTHING IS FOR YOU!
AND THIS ONE THING IS FOR HIM!
>> WELLS FOR BOYS BY FISHER
PRICE.
DON'T JUST GIVE HIM A BARBIE.
I MEAN, IT IS LIKE THAT BUT
THAT'S JUST PART OF IT.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]